don't bring anyone love into this you
were high as fuck right you're your host
I mean I've been I've been blackout
drunk a number of times I've never assam
here I've puked yeah I puked like in my
sleep when I was yeah that's how you die
yeah but I was faced in Carmen oh yes I
did one really bad sleepwalking thing
where I walked out I was 19 I walked out
of my dorm
toko took a right and just these girls
dorms and open up their laundry basket
and piston and laundry basket whoa I had
no recollection of it whatsoever did
somebody see you doing it yes really so
I came back to my dorm the next day and
they're like there he is I only have
four beers that's exactly where my
bathroom would be at my parents house
but I mean that's grounds for expulsion
yeah one time in college I went to sleep
with my dorm room unlocked because I
think my roommate was gonna come in
later and she'd never care whatever I
woke up in the middle of the night to a
girl pissing on my carpet yep she was
fully squatting and piss a stranger I'd
never seen this girl on campus before
and I go I I think you have the wrong
room you need to leave I turn the light
on I thought it was my roommate we need
to leave she goes oh I just came in here
I was gonna read this book and she
picked up a copy of my book and then she
laid on my roommates bed and started to
read the book and I go you need to get
out of here right now I'm calling Public
Safety you need to get out of here and
she's like oh okay I think she was
sleepwalking or she's really high and
she pissed on my floor got into my
roommates bed and read my roommates book
and I was like you need to get out of
here you need to get out here and then
she finally was okay and she was dazed
and she left it was so bizarre
of course what I call Public Safety and
I filed a report like yeah it was crazy
it was bananas wait when you when you
the next day when people were like here
he is yeah that's nuts
no I know it's nuts because they weren't
really that mad at me that's what's
crazy or they must have really
understood what was going on
I suppose they they say I don't feel
like I would be that cool they said
they'd walk me back to
they go in a bed but it's like I still
have no recollection of it whatsoever
not like bits and pieces doing nothing
yeah and I was drinking that night for
beers though that's not really a four
beers kind of move no it's for me it
would be I mean I had some Everclear
blackout that's different you know yeah
what is that what your alcohol yeah it's
like grain alcohol we've missed it with
Gatorade yeah and I mean I mean crazy
shit what is it with boys and Everclear
like freshman year in college guys got a
one-up each other and they got to do
more it's about how fucked up can you
get yeah cuz that's the goal most
interesting man in the dough sakis
commercial it's the world's most fucked
up man for sure that's what you want to
do I remember beer boring and shit and I
think the next day after those you would
never no one was ever like that was fun
right it was always panic because
because of the blackout you had no
recollection so I'd be like what
happened and then you have the anxiety
of somebody telling you something
terrible yeah so it's like it would
always be like you know your friend
would start with their head shaking
you're like what like that kill somebody
you know and then they're like well no
but I think oh my god like it's a
strange thing when you're robbed of your
memory yeah you feel terrifying it's
terrifying then it's not supposed to be
like that ya know it's a scary thing
you've never blacked out I've done acid
too much at one time and that's that
warps your sense of time but I told you
about that one where I went to a thing
with work people when I started
interning here in LA yeah and I went to
that sushi place uh-huh and we were just
I was just yeah it wasn't ever clear but
I was pounding yeah sake and stuff yeah
and then I was talking to a group of
them and I was super fucked up and then
you know they told me I don't remember
he's actually like it was cute
telling a circle of people oh my god and
then the guy told he goes after you
puked you know and you're going you puke
you yeah yeah yeah
spittin like everybody's like yeah and
they used you turn back he went right
back into the stage and then I do stole
that from I have a vague recollection of
being you know escorted out like
security and be like get this guy at it
right well was the story why was all
important I think I think I just liked
holding court just enjoy you know lots
of thing because it can't feel good when
you're that age just to get super hammer
like just vomit every time you drink no
no no no but I should have but nobody
always goes that hard yeah I also you
know I didn't know how to do like have a
drink and just hang in joint if and if
something wasn't exciting going on I'd
be like well just keep drinking you know
there's no action it's like just keep
drinking that's the mistake I would make
yes I would just hang out for too long
okay well conversations are kind of over
with everybody I'm just gonna keep
drinking till something happens or
before uber was around I go out and I
live in my twenties and just be stuck at
places oh my god and crowded you can't
really talk to anybody I just I guess
I'm just gonna drink yeah
disaster of course I had that the worst
part of that one of the puking one was
that I would that was like a Saturday
night mm-hmm
so you recover Sunday yeah Monday I went
to that job is that one you didn't go
into a hard time in college I had some
black out drink thing with where I was
interning and then I went back to school
and when I went I got hired by the place
to work there there was a lady who I
don't know she was
she was 20-some years older than me it
would kind of like say you know when
somebody says something with like a she
had she was delicate about she was
tactful about it but like almost
implying something is there and I was
like what is up with like not even like
that there's something when action
action she was like saying she would
imply something familiar you know like I
didn't even know her I'm like who is
this ha ha ha
so I remember after a week of working at
this place I go have you seen I don't
remember her name like the way Shannon
looks at me or says uh like some things
and they're like yeah I mean don't you
think that's kind of weird like I've
never even met her and they go you made
out with my god that that before you
left
oh yeah yeah at the bar you made out
with her in public at the park in front
of everybody here everybody knows that
you guys made out and I was like what I
had zero told you must have loved that
moment oh the other no oh yes what could
feel better than to feel like you don't
know this was not attractive woman lady
I think at the time I must have been
quite the I was her getting her groove
back that was 21 right she was 44 45 yes
and she what would she look but she
looked like the pizza dump lady and she
wasn't that bad she was just a big dick
and balls
very nice dick nice back she had a hairy
ass it was my style but she she was very
plain plain Jane like very like very
just act like unassuming you would walk
right past her I didn't think anything
of it you know and and I I mean I can't
believe in which when I was finally so
great I remember being like and I just
what I decided to do was just act like
everything was completely you mean when
every 20 year old boy does just act like
nothing yes yes that's what you do at
the office anyways though I'm so good
yeah yeah yeah just pretend it's what
Don Draper does is what I do
yeah that's true cuz I also hooked up
with I hooked up with someone more
age appropriate at that office and then
I acted the same way I was like I don't
know you and then oh my god
but actually that I ended up not
obviously working in offices for the
rest of my life but that experience
taught me how horrible an idea it is to
hook up with anybody that you work with
I mean I I know it's an lesson you can't
learn through somebody else I can
appreciate that but I've told especially
other young guys I've been like don't do
it it'll make work terrible
[Music]